الدريس
وان يكون هناك مشاركه كافيه
للمراه وتقديم في تقديم كل الخدمات ذلك
نحن بحاجه لهذا الوقت للمشاركه بشكل فاعل
وان نخرج بحلول امل ان اكون قد اوضحت
موقفا
الاول مشابه للسؤال السابق
ان الحضر كان
انه اثر على عمل لكم
اسوء حالات انتم وفريقكم المحلي هل كنتم
هل انتم مستعدين لاثار لذلك وتبعته ماذا
اعددتم
لمواجهه هذا الوضع ثانيا ود ان اعرف منك
ماذا تتوقعون ان يكون تعامل المجتمع
الدولي مع طالبا من اجل
التراجع عن هذا القرار شكرا لك ابدا
بالجزء الثاني من السؤال واعود للاول
كل الشركاء وكل المجتمع الدولي مشارك
بالحوار مع طالبان من اجل الصلاه لهذه
الرساله التي تحدثنا عنها اليوم وهي ان
همم المراه عضو اساسي بالمجتمع ولابد من
تربيه احتياجاتها وان اخراج المراه من
الحياه العامه ووضع كل هذه القيود لن يؤدي
الى نتائج بناء سواء للاقتصاد او الحياه
الاجتماعيه او اي جانب اخر لمستقبل
افغانستان كنا واضحين معهم في ذلك همم
مشاركه المراه ضروريه وهمم
ذلك مهم
وكذلك استدامه الحوار مهم جدا هذا لابد من
استكماله
هل لي ان اسالك هنا هل لديكم اي نصيحه
واقتراحات المجتمع الدولي للمشاركه بشكل
اكثر فاعليه مع طالبا
نحن نعمل
الحياه الاقتصاديه والوضع الاقتصادي
وبتركيز على
الجوانب المتعلقه بعمل المراه
والعمل في قطاع المنظمات غير الحكوميه هو
اكبر مشغل للمراه في افغانستان ولست واثقا
كان همم القرارات التي تمت او الحوارات
حول حظر المراه من العمل في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه همم
ان همم
اعداد النساء العاملات في هذا القطاع وفي
كثير من الحالات هؤلاء النساء هن من يكسبن
قوته اسريهننا
فمساء الاقتصاد ومشاركه الشعب وخاصه
المراه والفتاه
امر مهم جدا
وبالنسبه لما تفعله الامم المتحده لمواجهه
هذا الوضع همم لدينا كثير من الخطط الطارق
لان كل هذه القطط هي لصالح الشعب الافغاني
ما نقوم به وما نخطط به هو لتقديم الدعم
للشعب بقدر الامكان لان هذا هذه واحده من
ان لم تكن الافقر فهي واحده من افقر الدول
في العالم هذا ما نهدف اليه
وبالتالي فاننا ناسف ان نرى اثر تلك
القرارات على برامجنا وان لم تمكن من
تنفيذ هذه البرامج او او
تحقيقها فانا سيكون هناك طبيعات لذلك